bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france 3 ans et demi heure de
brouille
à quoi peut-on attribuer ce retour en
grâce du qatar quelles sont les raisons
de fond en fait depuis les gens moins
deux ans si vous voulez l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats arabes unis
avait réalisé que le qatar avait
finalement remporté 7 7 cette guerre qui
lui avait été imposée leucate a réussi à
contourner le blocus qui lui était
imposé en se rapprochant la turquie et
de l'iran alors que c'était le but
exactement opposée à ce qu'ils étaient
recherchés par ryad et abu dhabi
et puis il y a eu la proximité avec les
élections américaines qui ont fait que
l'arabie saoudite
mohammed bin salman le prince héritier a
d'une certaine manière voulu faire
plaisir à joe biden qui n'est pas n'a
pas été comme vous le savez sont son
candidat pour la présidence américaine
joe biden qui voudraient faire pression
sur l'arabie saoudite en matière de
droits de l'homme et là par conséquent
mohammed bin salman lui offre une
possibilité justement de voir une crise
entre alliés des américains régler avant
même son arrivée à la maison blanche
donc c'est tout ça qui a compté c'est à
la fois le réalisme je dirais un peu
poussé contre 1 qui a poussé ryad à se
rapprocher du qatar passe comme ça a été
dit dans votre reportage finalement
qatar est le grand gagnant de cette
percée diplomatique parce que
effectivement ils n'ont pratiquement pas
c'est l'ère van ne connais pas le détail
mais on peut imaginer quand même que le
qatar n'a pratiquement pas céder la fef
al jazeera va rester toujours une chaîne
de télévision qui de temps à autre va
servir de poil à gratter pour le pour le
qatar le qatar va garder sa relation
stratégique avec la turquie 1 au grand
dam de l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
arabes unis le qatar ne servira pas non
plus
de lancement pour une attaque américaine
contre l'iran donc effectivement
l'arabie saoudite ne dirais pas réaliste
aux contraintes s'est dit c'est le
moment de un petit peu de tourner la
page et d'amorcer cette réconciliation
mais ça n'est qu'une ça n'est qu'une
première étape parce que parce que à
côté de l'arabie saoudite il ya les
émirats arabes unis qui eux ont une
position une posture anti qatarienne
très très forte avec un élément central
qui les différencie c'est l'appui
justement qatariens aux frères musulmans
pour les émirats arabes unis c'est une
c'est une véritable obsession
les émirats arabes unis et le qatar sont
en guerre en libye notamment
et donc même si ce soir ou demain matin
plus tôt les avions vont de nouveau volé
entre doha et dubaï ce qui va rendre
service à beaucoup de devises nessman de
la région et bien eu la méfiance qui
existait entre le qatar et les laver et
les émirats n'a pas ne va pas remettre
du jour au lendemain donc voilà il
faudra voir un petit peu comment cette
réouverture des relations diplomatiques
va se passer il dédiera une crise en
2014 lorsque ces mêmes pays avaient
retiré leur ambassadeur du qatar pour
pour manifester leur colère contre eux
ce qu'ils considèrent comme un un appui
qatariens ou comme jugement est il trop
grande proximité avec l'iran c'est le
crise n'avait pas été il ya eu quelques
petits gestes qui avait été adoptée par
le qatar insuffisant pour ses voisins il
ya eu la crise de 2010 est aujourd'hui à
nouveau une réconciliation mais il
faudra voir un petit peu comment ça se
passe dans la réalité est dans les
détails ça sera assez compliqué je pense
alors vous parliez de joe biden georges
malbrunot mais enfin en attendant il y
avait un petit peu l'ombre de donald
trump qui planait sur cette
réconciliation avec la présence de yann
kouchner a le gendre conseiller du
président sortant qui présent ce qui
n'était évidemment pas fortuite
c'est une sorte de nouvelle
victoire diplomatique de donald trump
avant de partir en tout cas c'est la
dernière devrait semblablement rares
open on peut le supposer
mais c'était effectivement une victoire
diplomatique vous faites bien de le
rappeler il y avait jared kushner qui a
été l'artisan justement ce rapprochement
entre l'arabie saoudite
notre son combat on peut le dire avec
bin salman et puis et puis
cheikh tamim du qatar mais pour moi avec
des salles mal c'est aussi une façon de
faire une pierre deux coups il rend
hommage à jared kushner administration
trump qui le à la poupée des faux
souvenirs de la faire caca shogi donald
trump a sauvé littéralement mohamed et
de salmane
et donc aujourd'hui nbs mohammed bin
salman lui renvoie l'ascenseur en
finalement offrant à l'administration
américaine sortante une dernière
victoire diplomatique
et puis domaine co c'est ce que je
disais à la même occasion c'est ce que
disait eh bien ils déchargent jo by lm
du crise la gestion d'une crise entre
alliés donc oui il ya effectivement
l'héritage de cette administration
américaine qui a réussi effectivement à
force de pression avec la médiation du
corps et a à faire que bien l'arabie
saoudite et au qatar et les émirats et
bien se réconcilier en tout cas amorce
une réconciliation mais qui encore une
fois va être va être difficile à régler
parce que parce qu'en fait vous l'avez
compris les racines des tensions et bien
les problèmes n'ont pas été respectées
traiter le qatar restera toujours un
supporter de l'islam politique est
d'être un musulman le qatar restera
toujours alliée avec la turquie le qatar
a gardé de bonnes relations avec l'iran
et tout ça risque de continuer de
déplaire à ses voisins alors tout est
une question de mesure il pourrait y
avoir une diminution la présence
militaire turque à doha il pourrait y
avoir il va y avoir en tout cas c'est
sur une réduction de la propagande anti
saoudienne et entier mais rien sur al
jazeera c'est vers ça il y aura aussi
beaucoup moins d' attaques sur les
chaîne saoudienne est brillant
qatar mais voilà le lever le diable se
cache dans le détail et ça va être ça va
être très compliqué de réinstaurer la
confiance y compris entre les peuples
parce qu'elle est beaucoup d'eux et
beaucoup d'eux il ya une véritable
guerre de l'ombre guerre de
l'information qui a eu lieu ces
dernières années sur les réseaux sociaux
des attaques personnelles etc
même si notamment de qatariens et
saoudiens c'est souvent les mêmes tribus
avec le même nom donc la halle ces
tribus étaient séparées aujourd'hui ils
vont pouvoir se rencontrer les ai encore
beaucoup beaucoup d'acrimonie beaucoup
de ressentiment et et le pour apaiser
tout cela eh bien il faudra du temps
merci beaucoup en tout cas georges
malbrunot grand reporter au figaro
spécialiste du moyen-orient merci à vous